what um what do you think it's gonna
take for the quote-unquote crypto world
to completely blur the line with the not
encrypt their world and it's less about
is that a crypto project or not a crypto
project and it's just is that something
that users are gonna use yeah I think we
haven't this is a really hard part okay
so what I always say is we've figured
out how to create crypto assets we
figure it out how to distribute them and
sell them through these new forms of
capital formation we figured out how to
speculate on them right like most of the
quote-unquote infrastructure the picks
and shovels people are investing in our
exchanges it's about financial
speculation
well we haven't figured it out yet is
how to utilize this stuff and what we
haven't figured out yet is the
specificity between proof of stake
protocol a previous take protocol be
like what it's like a fork right a fork
is a very specific tool that you use for
very specific thing what's the
specificity for something like Bitcoin
versus something like Z cash or Manero
or - all right that specificity
narrative hasn't really started to
evolve yet because no one's really using
this stuff so I wrote this post back in
March of 2018 called drowning in tokens
and my whole premise was that what we're
doing right now is we're just pumping
out a ton of supply but there's no
demand
there's artificial demand and
speculative demand but there's no
utility demand and without a real demand
function you can't really model growth
and and that's the problem until we find
natural demand for this stuff it's very
hard to see where the future might go we
can have ideas but we haven't seen that
many projects reach the mass market and
start to eat away at the market share of
payments companies or to generate an
entirely new type of demand we just
haven't seen that yet yep
and that's what's interesting to me and
it goes back to like these concepts that
have been around in the business school
community sorry where I come from for a
while like adoption curves the
innovation s-curve right it's really
China think about we're so early
we're either so earlier we're so late in
the adoption curve I actually don't know
anymore
mmm-hmm like maybe the total addressable
market for Bitcoin is really small maybe
that's just a reality and I think in its
current iteration the total addressable
for market market for Bitcoin is
actually quite small because it's too
hard to use right there are a limited
number of people have the competency in
the capacity and frankly the interest of
using it in its current iteration so
then it's technical innovation but also
product innovation that creates a larger
addressable market and I don't think
we've really started to think through
that people had ideas like when earn
calm went back when it was 21 came out
with their initial idea that was a cool
idea at the time right like I actually
thought that that could have been an
interesting way to spread adoption and I
know people laugh at the idea of mining
with a toaster I think that's kind of
the narrative that said it was actually
a really cool idea it was just way too
early and the form factor the 21
computer was way too hard yep and I
think they realized that and they were
like this site this is a great idea but
probably like two rows ten years to
really